It can happen that your job, which you really liked, suddenly becomes tiresome...
...and your relationships with clients and colleagues turn sour.
Why? It is possible that there is nothing wrong with your job, but that you need some time off.
But it could also be an indicator that you are fed up with your work.
To find out which it is, you should count the negative and positive impacts.
Negative aspects include questions like: Do you hate the idea of going to work on Sunday night?
Are you bored at work? Do you think negatively about your work?
Has your performance become worse?
On the positive side, questions should include: Do you apply all your skills and talents?
Is the team culture at work enjoyable? Do you feel respect for your co-workers and clients?
Do you feel happy with the available professional development and progress?
Can you take the initiative at work?
Having looked at these questions, what is the answer?
Do you need a little or a permanent break?